now what what do you think about when
you think about the name joppa stone
what comes to mind when you think about
joepa stone
well joe was uh i remember i got in the
bureau in 80
and in 81 uh i met joe and i actually
have an autograph book of his uh joe is
like one of the many
pioneers of undercover there was a
handful of guys
guys like willie reagan paul branagh
eddie rob
et cetera joe is one of them and and
keep in mind
people don't understand this but
undercover work is an investigative
scenario
just like it is in surveillance or
wiretaps that's all it is
and sometimes you're lucky sometimes
you're successful other times you're not
other times your original plan snowballs
into a bigger plan
joe being one of the uh i guess
for lack of brother were pioneers of
this
he was at a time when and i saw this
change in the bureau when i first
started doing undercover
there was nobody watching you 24 7. you
were kind of on your own you did what
you had to do and then you came back you
called the case agent
and you met him and you talked them you
told them what went on well now that's
changed to
you know you've got full coverage on you
uh joe what he did i thought he did an
excellent job
with it uh in that again he's one of the
pioneers him and eddie rob
was another guy that they worked
together in some case and they set the
groundwork for us to
to do these cases you know so i got i
got a question for you i asked him i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
about this
i asked joe when we did the interview
i said joe you know i've interviewed
other mobsters
and you sound more like you're a mobster
then mobsters sound like they're a
mobster
you dress like one you put the glasses
you're quiet you don't say a lot you
watch you're very
calculating etc etc i said i said
did it ever get to a point because this
is my assumption and i said i want to
hear your answer
i said did it ever get to a point where
you
enjoyed the life too much so much that
you wanted to drag it out where the fbi
finally said
you kind of crossed the line you you
could have saw this two three years ago
but you've dragged this out for six
years because we're under the impression
that you're actually enjoying the life
and uh if you've seen the interview
you'll know what he said but i'm curious
to know
what do you think do you think it got to
a point where maybe joe was enjoying her
life a little bit too much and he didn't
want to get away from it
you know i've never experienced that and
i'll tell you why i've
i've worked over a hundred undercover
cases
as well as countless by bus so my career
is i jump from one case to the other
so if you have a case and it's good and
it's give you all the toys i mean i
played everything from
big i've driven rolls-royce's 500
e uh hummers h2 some are h1s
i i've driven all and i've had
everything and
for me was like okay you shut it down
hey
maybe you're short-sighted and shutting
it down but i'll move on to another case
i think joe was one of those guys who
worked maybe a handful of cases
so i don't know the background of why
he want uh to keep it going but my thing
has always been and i've had fights
and in fact if reading my book at the
end i have fights with management
because i've always was trained on the
covers that when you work a case
you walk up the ladder is everything has
to go you try to get as long as you're
gathering evidence as long as
you're pursuing as long as there's
nobody's life in danger
or there are no threats you keep
marching until you can't march anymore
unfortunately in my case after two and a
half years
almost three they pulled a plug for no
reason there was no
nobody didn't believe that i was
anything but jack falcone
my life was not in danger i wish i would
have gotten the five or six years that
joe
got you know so it but it wasn't it was
curtailed for whatever reason
now did that upset me and the united
states attorneys that worked the case
and the case agents
absolutely but what can we do we're just
points
so i moved on to another case and did
what i had to do
in hindsight yes the case was successful
we took down
the administration of the post scotty
but
you know i wish we could have more time
i wanted to
even go to the possibility of getting
straight now so i can introduce other
agents
uh into the fold and maybe try to get
that 32
into whatever to dismantle the uh the
whole group
so were you ever in it where jack were
you ever in it where you're like man i'm
i enjoy this life was there anything
about it that got you enamored where you
were enjoying the life and you didn't
want to leave it
well you know if you talk to people
about i've enjoyed
you have to enjoy working undercover no
matter what you're doing
i mean i've enjoyed flying jet planes
with drug dealers you know i
i all we enjoyed i mean the toys the
the the pinky ring the rolex president
watched the money i used to carry a knot
like five g's in my pocket
now you ask me lucky i got ten dollars
on me you know yes i used to walk in a
restaurant
waiters tripped themselves over to try
to take care of big jackie boy
you know how many do now i get sent to
the bar and wait for my table you know
these are all
changes that are adjusted yes when
you're out and undercover
you're acting you take this persona
because you
in order to catch a criminal you have to
think and act like a criminal yep
so you have to play the roles but you
have to also understand
that this is temporary i had clothes i
had
uh senior suits that were bought with
government funds that i had to return
even my underwear and socks now who is
going to buy a 66
long suit yes because it's property
so i've learned all my career
i've learned through my career that you
know patrick that
enjoy it go out there enjoy it hey
listen
it's dangerous keep your eyes we used to
go to when i was on the cover
we go to these restaurants we take over
these restaurants that we're in contact
we have five or six wise guys with about
five strippers
you know what i'm saying it was like
champagne was flowing
i mean this is what these guys do you go
out sometimes i went for manny petty's
never had a mani pedi
until i was with the mob you know i had
cucumbers
you know i just think like hillary would
have known what a cucumber was hillary
right
baldwin but anyway that's another story
but yeah
it is seductive it's a seductive
mistress it's something that takes you
over
and you got to be careful because you
it's going to end and if you think it's
going to go on forever
it's not and if it starts affecting who
you are
you better walk away uh jack the 26 you
were in as an fbi how many years of it
were you married
i got married in 84 so i was uh
listen my wife i think was a saint let
me tell you the success that i think
i've had
okay is because of her and my daughter
okay they grounded me i even though i
never saw them because i had my own
apartment
very rarely do i saw them it was like
when i spoke to them and even if i
missed a recital even if i missed a
holiday
okay cheating pressure me or get on me
and that's important because you need to
have a clear head
when you're out there with the bad guy
you don't need to have oh my god my
wife's mad at me she's going to leave
she called me
she was very good and i think because
she lived in
with in law enforcement prior to that
with a ference
then i think that's what made the edge
but marriage i've seen this job
patrick where it's affected people's
marriage it's effective their drinking
i've affected all kinds guys have gone
to the dark side
okay the only thing this job did to me
is destroy my weight
my weight i mean i i i have issues
because of that
because i learned how to eat but hey
that could be worse you know what i'm
saying i mean
it but it does do something to you
there's a lot of peril
and not too many guys could sustain
undercover the guys who say yeah i
worked undercover what one
two years you know when you're out there
15 years
20 years you know it's grinding it it
does things to you
you know so you're still married to the
same wife from 1984. that is correct
let me i mean she deserves a purple she
deserves a
medal medal of honor type of deal she
does and my daughter was born in the
year
2000 keep in mind because i was never
home
so yes if you do the math she was 2 000
and then when i left the bureau in 2005
okay i went from driving greg de palma a
captain in the gambino crime family to
driving
my five-year-old daughter around and
patrick let me tell you there's no
difference
they both want things buy me this get me
that and give me this
non-stop wow wow
you know i i hear these stories and i
think with
stone as well i think he's still married
to the same wife by the way
you know he is still married to the same
wife so it's interesting
both of you guys haven't served as long
as you did and you're still married to
the same woman and you lived a
very difficult life of a person to stay
married to
that is true and it was weird because
when i would come home
those rare moments did she know what she
did she knew what she did she knew i was
in the fbi and of course i've worked
undercover no no she
you know she did know i was working on
the cover because i would come in to see
her
you know how do you explain having an s
500 mercedes
and you know when you're driving a
regular car so
all the toys you know the ring like my
wife would say to me
we got to go to the recital you go there
you look like a gangster you got the
ring the rolex watch
my daughter kept saying i want to take
daddy to show your daddy what she does
at work
what are you going to say yeah my name
is jack falcone i am
again an associate in the gambino crime
family
so you you miss and it does stick with
you
being undercover it's very seductive and
i
understand why guys go bad
and things have done because not too
many people could
could do it or put up with it